It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we will host a FUWAMOCO Morning!
Huh?
It's totally normal, no squeaking.
No!
Squeaking is normal because today is the 151st episode!
I thought you were gonna make a mistake.
No.
BAU BAU, thank you for joining us waking up early!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
Especially if you went to sleep so early.
Biboo, you had lots and lots of fun yesterday, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I think I see a few Ruffians.
Maybe today is your first FUWAMOCO Morning!
Maybe you're a little bit confused like what is this FUWAMOCO Morning?
It's simple.
Wow!
For those joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Now remember,
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good morning!
You went to sleep and you woke up?
Yes!
BAU BAU!
We hope that you're feeling refreshed and ready to take on the day of love with us.
Maybe if you're not.
Hopefully this will help a bit.
A smidgen of a bit.
Just a smidgen of a bit.
It'll make us happy.
Well you know, Moco-chan.
You didn't sleep?
Well, hopefully this gives you some more energy!
This is the best way to start the day!
BAU BAU!
It's the best way for us to start our day.
FUWAMOCO-chan, this is the part that we all kind of feel a little bit disappointed, right?
Okay, Moco-chan.
Ruffians!
Where was Pero Sighted this time, Moco-chan?
No Ruffians fighting panel on!
No fighting.
No!
Huh?
Yes.
Oh!
That's good, you know, we don't need any more nasty ones.
What?
Nani?
No.
No?
No, we don't need any more nasty ones.
No, it's a nice break, you know.
Only fluffy and fuzzy today, right?
Is he okay?
Does he need a hug?
This fool has been defeated, yes!
Hug fluffies, are you sure?
I think that's gonna be really dangerous.
He's been defeated for Wednesday.
You miss him!
Miss him!
Am I hoarding something?
I don't know.
That's a lot of credit you're giving him there.
Is FUWAMOCO gonna eat Pero?
Do you think he eats garbage?
You're saying that we would like to eat garbage and I feel slightly insulted, Ruffians.
Well, well.
A day with a little more... Nastiness.
Yes.
BAU BAU!
Pero's definitely a marshmallow.
I think you're very confused.
She's definitely a demon dog.
Pero seed marshmallow set.
Then you can go camping, and then put him on the campfire and watch him melt away!
Or then you can, you know, put him in your mug and then put boiling hot water on him!
Delicious and sort of violent.
BAU BAU!
Let's get on to the rest of the day!
Today is the day, you know, that my very beloved Soic-senpai!
Greta-senpai!
This is the last day that she's here with us in hololive.
You know, it's really hard to say goodbye.
Especially, you know, there's still so much we wanted to do, to be able to talk about with her, you know, just everything together with Greta-senpai, but...
She held her last karaoke stream yesterday and it was beautiful!
We were able to listen to a bit of it.
I'm really happy.
But in case you missed it as well!
Gura-senpai, she released her last big project the other day!
A brand new original song called Ash Again.
Created together with Casey Edwards known for his game music and Devil May Cry.
Have you listened?
It was amazing.
Not only is it an incredible song,
Wow, but the animation, the feelings, the emotion, just everything's so raw.
It's so beautiful.
It's super powerful.
It's just a breathtaking mass performance by Gura-senpai.
So if you haven't checked it out, it's so much to go.
Yeah, please go get it too, okay?
And I'm sure you know Gura-senpai would be very happy that you watched it today too, so.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Gura-senpai!
But!
Before!
There's gonna be a very special Myth Club Relay!
Happening before Gura-senpai has her very last graduation scene!
And!
We'll have some new moves!
It seems like it's going to be starting over on Calli-senpai's channel!
At 1pm PT or 5am JST.
They'll be playing Minecraft.
I think.
Minecraft.
Yes.
And then, they will continue over to Kiara-senpai's channel at 2pm PT, 6am JST.
Playing Jackbox Games.
FUWAMOCO And then, continuing with our train over to Ina-senpai's channel starting at 3pm, 7am JST, they're gonna be playing Gang Beasts!
FUWAMOCO And then, FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO
I think they have another small collab?
I don't know.
I'm not too sure, but I'm looking forward to it.
That will be from 4pm PT to 4pm- 430pm!
4pm 30?
PT!
And then Gura-senpai's final 3D Mini Live will be happening at 5pm PT, 9am TST.
So let's all
See Gra-senpai off with a smile.
Let's say thank you from the very depths of our hearts.
The depths of our hearts ocean.
BAU BAU!
Calli stream starts very soon in about 4 hours.
The relay starts soon.
I'm gonna send you over there, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Special pop-up store.
What does it take to go there?
What is it?
Right now!
It's free!
You don't need any tickets to visit.
You can just walk right on in!
And there you know, there's special merch in these zero gravity battle outfits here.
Acrylics, tapestries, a bunch of different cool things to be able to buy in the store there.
And because it's a pop-up, it's limited time, okay?
It will pop up and then it will be gone.
And it ends on May 29th, so you still have some time.
Maybe you're planning a Japan trip, or maybe you have a friend who's planning a Japan trip.
You can pop on by.
You know what?
But!
We talked about this.
There's one important thing.
There's an important thing at this pop-up shop.
We can't get away though!
At this pop-up shop, you can meet FUWAMOCO!
Yes!
FIGURE!
One one skill, life size, FUWAMOCO!
In resin, in figure.
We're not so rough with you because you can't touch, we ask.
Because you don't!
Did you notice?
At the bottom of it!
Not that bottom there.
That's our...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It was a chance.
Moco-chan.
I have a photo nobody else has.
Huh?
Of who, Moco-chan?
It's a chance!
How could you do that in front of Mari-chan?
I don't think the Ruffians can walk around.
You know, the Ruffians are not able to walk around.
I did it at the last moment.
I think everyone had their back turned.
But there's a lot of surprises.
And what was most surprising, especially to Moco-chan, you know, we got handed the pens.
FUWAMOCO please, if you could, if you could sign the base of the stand.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
And always 1-1 scale is very impressive, but I feel like often the painting leaves a bit to be desired.
You know, but you're like, oh it's 1-1 scale, you know?
It's a pain.
This is not that.
This is amazing!
This is the most amazing 1-1 scale figure I have ever seen.
Quite possibly that could ever be created, you know?
Absolutely unbiased.
The translucent materials!
Yes!
You know, the airbrushing!
The airbrushing is amazing!
The sculpting!
The use of materials!
You know, just looking at all the angles!
Every angle!
Everything!
Everything is beautiful!
Did you look at the nails?
I looked at the nails.
We looked in the shoes.
Did you look behind the jacket?
We looked, we looked, we looked and looked and looked.
And then finally, we got handed the pen.
And that was where the panic started.
Moco-chan got the sign first, which was a mistake.
I don't think anyone looked at the signature right.
Moco-chan's like, I have to make sure I do this right.
I only get one chance.
Could you imagine if I made a mistake?
Moco-chan already had the pen down on the stand.
FUWAMOCO-chan fashion.
You need to press down on the pen really hard.
I flooded it!
I flooded the zero.
The circle.
No!
The what?
The big puddle in the middle of it.
I flooded it!
Oh no!
And then I picked up the pen and then it dropped everywhere!
It just... I looked up and the staff was like... What do I do?
What do I do?
Moco-chan's panicking and the staff is like... What do we do?
What do we do?
We can't... We can't wipe it.
We can't... No.
No.
Continue.
It just continued.
And then I made it into a... Yeah, FUWAMOCO's suggestion, right, Moco-chan?
I'll make a mistake.
Cute.
And that's why it's called BAU BAU.
I tried!
Looks like a baseball player.
Do baseball players make mistakes like this all the time?
All the time!
I just... I pushed down on the pen a lot.
The mistake makes it cuter!
You were wondering!
Huh?
You were wondering what happened here.
It's a pretty easy story.
What was the issue, Mococo?
What was the issue?
Mococo doesn't just press down as hard as she can when she writes her signature.
That was the issue.
I tried.
Yeah.
Meanwhile, my signature came out just as I had planned!
I should've went first though.
You should've went first.
I was just about to say that.
Do we have any other nice photos?
Do we have any other photos?
Moco-chan, do you have a favorite spot that the Ruffians can take a nice closeup look at?
I have a bunch of closeups.
There are a lot more close-ups online as well!
You can see other Ruffians posting lots of photos!
It's a little bit embarrassing, huh?
You know, close-up.
My tummy, everything's clinging and you know.
But the material used is very cute!
Yeah, you know, and the staff is always like, look!
Look, Fuwawa!
We worked so hard to be able to do this!
Make your belly button!
Look at the belly button!
Trust me, we know this.
The mouth is also very cute, the depth inside the mouth.
Look inside the mouth, okay?
And then Moco-chan!
Moco-chan's mouth is so cute too!
And also, you probably can't see that well, but if you look behind the jacket, you know, sort of in between the armpit and the jacket, it's also very interesting too!
Lots of different places to look!
Very cute!
You have to go if you can and take a look at Fursuit Ruffians!
Very very recommended!
Even if you think it's just a pop-up store, I'm not really interested in it anymore.
Please go see it, okay?
But we have good news for Ruffians!
I'm gonna be able to!
Right now, you can pre-order your own 1-7-6 FUWAMOCO figures!
All thanks to Design Coco!
Design Coco made these works of art!
You can pre-order them right now!
You can get them on AmiAmi too!
And we know some Ruffians have been concerned and we understand.
We understand.
They are not the um... What's the word?
They are difficult to get in your prize because of the price point.
Yeah, you know, but they work so hard.
But it's very understandable because there is a very... What's the word?
Gouka?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Important point that these are made to order.
If you don't pre-order, it's gonna get really hard to be able to get your password afterwards.
We have made this mistake many, many times, okay?
Because you think, oh, I'll just get it later.
Somebody will part with it maybe.
The good news is that you have 3 months to be able to decide.
You know, talk things over with your wallet maybe.
But if you want to see them closer!
Super cute right?
BAU BAU!
I can't wait to get a paw somebody.
Trust me Ruffians.
We do our best, but... But we also noticed too, Ruffians, that it seems like over at AmiAmi, that we are in the ranking for the Bishoujo for the cute girl figures!
Yes!
Bishoujo figures!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We are local right there!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
If you're like, I can't.
It's okay.
Because!
There is this!
Yeah!
Right now if you go over to Twitter.
Yes!
And you follow the A.S.K.L.I.T.E account and then you repost this.
This post with this image.
Yes!
And I will, after... After FUWAMOCO Morning, I will point you to this tweet.
If you do this, then you could win both Fuwawa and Mococo!
Yes!
I'm doing a special giveaway for it.
So, you know, if...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
We hope you're the best Ruffians!
I'm just really excited, so I wanted to talk a bunch about that.
We really really love figures.
Yeah.
And I really, really like all the materials.
And I love our outfits and everything.
Yeah.
Just really excited.
BAU BAU!
And I'm speaking of other things that are really big and life-size.
Almost life-size.
Big!
We're talking about big.
This is a big episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's not life-size.
But it's big!
The biggest plushies yet of FUWAMOCO!
I have both!
I'm about to descend on the earth.
We have these rapid-burning plushies from Abyssgard!
Look at us!
They're sitting on the pond, eating donuts!
You may think looking at this, that this is a plushie.
It's just a plushie.
I don't have anything for scale, I think for the photo.
Sitting down at this size, I think they are 53 centimeters tall.
I don't know what that is though, really.
That's okay, Ruffians!
We have had the pleasure to be able to get many many of these FUWAMOCOs, FUWAMOCO buddies and be able to overlook them.
Overlook, you know.
Give them lots of head pats and hugs.
They are big!
They are hefty!
At one point, I thought I was being overrun by them in a wonderful way.
But, okay.
They're so detailed.
And then, this is the special thing.
They give very, very special hugs.
Very good hugs.
It's like, they're happy.
It's like a big child.
You know, it's a plushie, right?
What's so special about it?
I don't know, when I just kind of picked up Moco-chan and gave Moco-chan a hug, just kind of like a tear came to my eyes.
It felt special.
I feel like if you need a hug, then it's probably pretty good.
So, as you know, you can take off the jackets, too!
There's a detachable jacket, headphones, and clothes, too, you know.
I was just amazed by all the details.
All the love that's went into these.
The stitching.
Yeah, so we hope both of you feel like, well, plushies, plushies are my thing.
If you like big plushies, this is your time.
It will not be on a shelf, okay?
No.
No, this is not a plushie you put on the shelf unless you happen to have ginormous shelves.
Yes, this is like it sits on its own chair.
This plushie demands a big portion of your home.
Okay.
This would be in a chair.
A chair is a good place.
I think it's very comparable.
Comparable?
It has a presence.
It has a presence, yes.
I don't think... Maybe not paying rent size, but...
Imposing.
At the very least, paying some of the grocery bills.
Helping out with chores.
Yes.
Maybe not paying rent.
Okay.
It commands pondering well.
It also comes with a place pondering as well.
You're in luck.
Please check it out.
You can get your paws on it over on Vivistar's website.
BAU BAU!
Not entirely.
That would mean rent.
This is a big episode of FUWAMOCO Morning, Ruffians!
It's been a while, but it's the time of the week!
Ruffians!
Moco-chan.
After what feels like it's been a very long time, Moco-chan is back!
Moco-chan's challenge is back!
BAU BAU!
You know it!
Pup Talk?
No!
It's time for Moco-chan's challenge, you know.
You know, it's been a while, so we want to be able to see just how much Moco-chan has grown and eating in the time since Anato Corner has been away, right?
Right, Ruffians?
Yeah, challenge.
Yeah.
So you know, today Moco-chan, you're going to challenge something.
That you've never done before!
Even though you know it's the middle of the week.
In the beginning of the week.
Challenge!
You know, and then you'll be ready to challenge something new this week, huh?
I love you!
Because Moco-chan, that's what you're doing.
And so today Moco-chan, you're probably curious what you're gonna be trying, right?
So today, Moco-chan, you're going to be challenging BILA!
BAU BAU!
BILA is also known as a loquat fruit.
It's yellow and orange and soft, maybe a little fuzzy too.
Yeah, apparently... You know what?
It tastes interesting.
We're not gonna spoil it.
Abiwa.
Yeah, abiwa.
A loquat fruit.
Yeah.
No, no, Mocomo!
Hey, you know, but Moco-chan is going to try something new and hopefully, you know, with that spirit of challenge, you know, you can continue to do your best and protect the Ruffian smile for many, many years to come, you know.
Just like me.
As I eat my natto daily.
It's sweet, right?
So I'm good.
Right?
Just because it's a fruit doesn't mean it's sweet, Moco-chan.
I've never had this before.
How confident are you, Moco-chan?
If it was a Japanese plum, that would be fine, but this is not.
It's a loquat fruit.
A loquat.
A beehive.
I'm eating it for the first time.
Moco-chan, you're confident.
I'm a bit nervous.
Don't spit it out, okay?
That's rude, okay?
Is there a seed?
Okay, FUWAMOCO-chan.
First, let's say thank you to the farmers in Kagoshima who worked hard to make this.
I didn't buy it anywhere close to Kagoshima.
Kagoshima?
Yeah.
Where's Kagoshima?
Far away.
Okay, FUWAMOCO-chan.
It's time to eat it from the tree.
Itadakimasu!
Um, not yet.
I have to figure out which side do I eat this from.
It's fuzzy all over.
Just stick it in your mouth, Moco-chan!
I'm gonna, I'm gonna... It's fuzzy though.
I'm gonna eat it like a cucumber.
Why?!
I'm gonna eat it like a cucumber, Moco-chan.
It's not spiky, it's fuzzy.
Do you eat the cucumber from the middle?
I don't know, I'm gonna try that.
Maybe not, I don't know.
Pick somewhere and bite!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Itadakimasu!
Are you supposed to take the skin off?
Okay.
It smells... It smells?
It smells... I don't know.
It smells like a fruit.
Okay!
Eat it like a kiwi?
I don't think so.
I think I just eat it.
That's one of the same sounds you make when you have natto, huh?
I don't know what that tastes like.
Get a bigger bite!
That was a small bite, Moco-chan.
I think... I hear fleas.
What?
I think it tastes like... an apple.
High-fived a mango.
It's more apple-y than a mango.
Like an apple high-fived a mango.
Is it seeds?
Did you find anything?
There's a big seed, it's like an avocado.
Avocado?
That's what it's shiny.
What?
What, Moco-chan?
I'm trying to hold everything.
Why are you spitting things out?
It's a scene!
You're putting it on my hand!
What the heck, Moco-chan?
It tastes very summery.
And very refreshing.
I feel like if you're thirsty, this would be a good replacement.
I'm gonna eat it, FUWAMOCO-chan!
I don't really like that side of it.
The inner part around the seed, I don't recommend eating that part.
One second, can I eat garbage?
Ha!
I'm just gonna take all your garbage from you!
I'm getting slimy now.
I'm gonna pull it off.
There.
Okay, and I'm not gonna eat the top part.
Oh, the top part?
I think it's good.
Compared to natto.
I think you could eat it in the morning.
It'd be good in a smoothie too.
It's sort of orangey too.
Sort of vaguely citrusy.
Perfect FUWAMOCO Morning, huh?
BAU BAU!
That was different from natto, huh?
I think my final review is it's... Apple?
High five the mango, right?
55% apple.
15% orange.
Rest mango.
Is that more mango?
It needs to be more apple.
Ah, orange.
Apple, orange, mango, that word, yes!
Moco-chan, would you like to do more corners like this?
I'm good.
Well, let's remember how brave Moco-chan was trying something new today!
And you know, we'll do our best this week to try things that we might be a little bit scared of too, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Well... Moco-chan... I have to eat something, then I have to do something else, huh?
I think you know... I think I said maybe you had...
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another well-needed Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians, I don't know about you, but recently we've been feeling like it's been a bit of an emotional time.
Do you maybe feel like that too?
Maybe not just one emotion, but a bunch of things.
Everything, you know?
And you just, you can't quite explain it.
Yeah.
Maybe you've been like this before.
Maybe not right now, but sometime, you know?
Maybe you feel a bit sad.
Confused.
Maybe a bit upset.
You just can't really figure it out.
At times like this when you feel a bit overwhelmed, it's good just to take a deep breath.
Take a bit of time to yourself, you know.
Relax.
Sort things out.
You know, go for a walk.
Have a nice bath.
Do something that you've been wanting to do and meaning to do but just haven't got to.
You know, maybe after a bit of time,
You'll be feeling a bit more like your usual self.
It might take a bit more time.
Maybe less time.
Let's just do what we can to support ourselves.
And if you're able to, support those around you who might be feeling the same too, okay?
You're amazing and resilient!
I know you can get through this, okay?
Feelings are complicated, so just take some deep breaths, okay?
Got it?
We believe in you!
Let's do this together, okay?
Got it.
BAU BAU!
Ganbatte de!
Thank you, Moco-chan.
Let's be Ruffians.
Let's do our best, okay?
I think there's a lot of...
Ruff times going on.
Cloudy feelings a bit too, but... Let's do our best, okay?
Let's do it!
Hello!
I think it's time we take a look at who's the Doggie of the Day today!
Yeah!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Skawo!
Skawo is cute!
What a baby!
Right?
Look at the very silly, proper ball.
The ball that ears a little bit.
I like the tummy.
The way Skawo is.
He sleeps like a deer though, huh?
How'd this go BAU BAU Moco-chan?
That's the zoomies.
But I feel like there needs to be a bit more of like the... You know the zoomies, but you know.
What a skilled person right by you.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Rufus.
BAU BAU!
Give this CD lotsa battle key!
And next we have our corner.
Today I went on a walk.
We have De-den!
Today I went on a walk around an aquarium.
Jellyfish!
Oh my gosh.
We look like we fit just in there together with the jellyfish, huh?
To be honest, when I see these jellyfish, I can tell they're real.
And then I think of all the jellyfish and I can tell both are fake.
They're so cute though, you know!
Thank you for taking us on an aquarium date together with you!
I think my favorite part of the aquarium is the jellyfish.
Yeah, you know.
They're like jellyfish.
The manta rays are very cute, right?
Yeah, I know.
They have the faces.
I like watching the jellyfish.
Sea slugs are kinda cool too.
Yeah!
Cuddlefish too.
You know, I think they're all pretty cool.
There's a lot of cool sea creatures too.
Yeah.
There's a Ruffian asked whether it's real.
I think it's real at an aquarium.
I don't think you need to ask.
Yeah.
Unless it's penguins.
Are those penguins fake?
Yeah, I don't think you need to worry.
No.
That would be a big deal though if all the aquarium animals were fake.
That could be cool in it's own way though.
It's like a wax museum but for aquariums.
People would go!
Idea I guess!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you for always sharing your walks with us, Mofus!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
You mentioned that oppai ice cream is pretty rare.
So where did you manage to find it during your trip?
Was it a dagashi shop?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians are maybe very confused at this moment.
That makes sense.
We had a very rare old school ice cream.
It's loved by kids but it's called Oppai Ice Cream.
There's different names too for it.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Yeah, and you know when we went on our little trip around Japan recently, we found it!
Yeah!
And we bought it so that our demon dog friend, so she could try it out.
Yeah, Japanese culture, you know!
And you know, in the past, you find these kind of ice creams at the dagashi and the dagashi shops.
It's like a candy store, a toy store.
Yeah, for kids, you know.
Usually very inexpensive, only a few yen.
Yeah, but, you know, now that last year they're rare themselves and this ice cream's even more rare!
But this time, we found it at a very large supermarket in the middle of nowhere.
Yeah, and they had almost every type of ice cream there.
I was really impressed.
Like it was ice cream and ice cream and ice cream and ice cream.
But, uh, yeah.
It's really rare.
That's why we bought it despite not having a freezer.
A freezer.
And there is five in the pack.
Yeah, you have to buy a lot of them.
Because that's how it was sold.
Did any of us really want to have ice cream at that moment?
Japanese culture, Moco-chan!
No, but it was a chance.
Yeah, and... Chance!
You take the chance!
In the end, it exploded everywhere.
hololive.
And the room.
Cups.
Every direction.
Controllers.
Not Moco-chan.
Books.
Yeah.
Carpet.
Sometimes it happens, I don't know about that.
It was worth it though!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much Ruffians for all your submissions for being a part, a very special part of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Remember!
Use the hashtag to send us your Doggie of the Day!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
And you know your Pero Sightings.
It's important to know where Pero is, especially maybe for the Ruffians who want to come across Pero.
Also your questions, you know, the walks you're going on.
Please let us know, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And we have another stream coming up soon!
De-den!
Wow!
At 3am!
3am PT!
It's a little bit early in the morning, but we can't help it, that's the business hours.
FUWAMOCO Cafe!
FUWAMOCO is opening up again for business!
Our main cafe!
I know, and this time we don't know what kind of hololive members will come to patronize our store.
We don't know.
Yeah, but...
We just have to hope that maybe we can survive in this economy, huh?
I guess.
Visit us.
There's a lot of competition when it comes to make out face.
Well, we'll just go out of business.
No set up shop.
Go on the next week.
We'll do our best.
BAU BAU!
A very special Rock n' Rawr Party!
It's gonna be on Thursday at 6pm P.T.
And we have a special announcement with that too!
Yeah, don't miss it!
We hope that you'll be there.
We'll be singing a bunch of anime songs, Japanese pop songs.
We don't know.
You don't know.
We'll find out.
We don't know.
You don't know.
We'll find out all together.
And then after that we're going to be having even more silly fun together with Donkey Kong Country 2.
We're playing it on our Smash Summerture Gaming.
And you know we both get to play.
Yeah.
Which is good because I'm pretty good at it.
K.O.
Moco-chan doesn't say anything.
BAU BAU!
And then later this week we have more FUWAMOCO Morning followed by a random FUWAMOCO Horror Game Matsuri.
We're going to be playing a bunch of different horror games.
I'm not too sure what's gonna happen.
There's a bunch of them.
A variety.
They're all gonna be really...
And then later this week we also have ENRECORD!
hololive English ENigmatic Recollection.
Chapter 2 starts later this week so we hope that you'll join us in all of hololive English for that as well!
And we have Metal Gear Solid 3 again later this week!
I can confirm that the PS2 is now off.
It is off and it will be on when it's time to play Metal Gear Solid 3.
Yes, pray for the PS2.
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!